okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS and
welcome to the uh Delta scalper analysis
for Wednesday July 26 2017 now a very
interesting day in the market a lot of
great uh a lot of good movement actually
you know for uh fed day the some of
these markets had some very nice uh
price action that there's a lot of nice
trades to be taken so I'll explain uh
the delta scalper in a minute but first
a brief disclaimer of this presentations
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a Futures Contract or make any other
type of investment decision Futures
training contain substantial risk and
it's not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results and where am I here so tools use
in this presentation are the Delta
scalper you can go to www.d Deltas
scaler.com to learn more about it or to
purchase interested if you so wish if
you are an existing user go to uh email
and type in upgrade deltas scaler.com
and I will send you out the uh upgrade
packet for you so uh without further Ado
let's take a look at some of these
markets now the you in in the other
presentation that I did on the orderflow
analysis I talked about crude oil and
you know I'll start there if I could
just find the chart it was the crude oil
eight range
chart okay well that's the footprint
chart uh let me you know I could talk
about it on the footprint chart but
honestly I find for the Delta scalper
analysis you know it runs on a normal
bar
chart as well as the uh footprint chart
so you know while you know some people
are are scared for the reason of a
footprint chart I I find the footprint
chart to be you know the best uh chart
out there for trading um the Delta
scalper will also work on a footprint uh
sorry a on a normal bar chart this is a
normal Candlestick chart you know
nothing fancy about it just a
Candlestick chart so let's take a look
since this
morning I don't know what time this was
3 in the morning a nice sell here
obviously after the inventory numbers
came out a beautiful sell here the sell
it started out didn't work out came back
up you who knows maybe you broke even on
that trade uh then you got another sell
here later in the day yeah I mean a few
bars lower you know it's from the what
is that 65 area down to you know the 50
45 area so that's 20 tick doesn't look
like much because you had this big
monster move here but you know these are
some nice trades this is a eight range
chart in the crude you know I prefer
range based charts as opposed to uh
minute based
charts because you know I like to see
how bars form as price moves not bars
form as the clock
moves okay and you know just compare it
really quick
to I think I got a FIV minute chart here
in crude oil
and here's the Delta scalper okay this
this is the evening session right now
let's open this up what do you got here
yeah you got to buy that you know you
got these big monster moves here but uh
yeah you didn't get much you these moves
will look bigger if I cut out that there
but yeah you had a decent move here this
one didn't work out this one stopped you
out this one yeah you know you know from
25 down to 18 you know that's not much
of a
move and here a a move up from you know
28 all the way up to you know 38 it's 10
ticks so you know this is a f- minute
chart so each bar is forming as as the
clock ticks um you know later no signals
the rest of the day um so you know the
people someone asked me the other day
you know what type of charts I like uh
obviously it's range based next would be
tick based last would be um minute based
I could throw in wrink Co charts I I
don't use wrinkled charts that much
anymore sorry that much I don't use them
at all anymore U just cuz I got so many
other charts I'm looking at uh I just
don't necessarily have that the time to
do it but um let's see how crude oil
looked on a 987 tick
chart okay so since this morning 987 is
a fib number you know that's that's why
Everyone likes to use 987 as as their
tick First Trade H it comes up stops out
second trade boom boom a nice winner so
you know first trade people oh Mike you
suck you're a scammer you're taking my
money for this indicator that blows well
you know your trading career is not
built on one trade right you know I've
been
trading I hate to use the term
institutionally because it sounds like
you're a mental patient but you I've
been trading you know for banks for
commodity firms you know not not just
for me in my socks you know in my
underwear in my basement no that's what
I did for a living right that's why you
know these indicators I develop are
based on how I traded you know how we
read the markets
so you here you got a nice move you know
again you know your career is not made
off of one little trade I know I you
know I I say that you know a bit of a
side I do know analysts that you know
try to make their career out of
predicting um you know the back after
the the crash in 2007 guys said buy snps
and you know the market obviously
rallied up and you know for the next 10
years until I retired from JP Morgan
you'd always pull that out oh I I I
predicted that rally in the s smps yeah
you and a lot of other people actually
but you know it got to the point where
you know I'd be having dinner with other
Traders and stuff and say yeah I met
with your analyst you know guy's still
talking about that damn S&P trade you
know it's like what have you done for me
lately you know now it's 2012 you know
it's five years later but he's like you
know having
a you know having his cake and eating it
too off of uh one nice trade but you
know it's about what have you done for
me lately sometimes but anyway you know
I digress I digress so 987 tick chart so
I've showed you so far an eight range
chart I've showed you a minute page
chart 5 minute chart and I'm now I'm
showing you a tick chart with the Delta
scalper same settings look at this
7111 1252 they're they're all the same
7112 52 so I'm not optimizing it it's
the same settings right whether you're
looking at a minute based a tick chart
or a range based chart so you got a nice
move here another nice move here um a
buy didn't really do much the sell
didn't do much then here you get a nice
Buy here you get a sell starts coming
into the number again this one is right
on the the data being released so you
most likely wouldn't be taking it this
one you probably could it's you know
good 10 minutes after the uh number data
was released and boom this was that move
that you saw on the uh eight range chart
as well nice monster move here you get a
little move lower um here not you know
and nothing it goes down comes right
back up you get a sell comes down again
and late in the day you get another sell
so that was crude you know I I'm showing
you know three different types of charts
on crude oil and you
know it works on each on each different
type of chart now you know is it like
that in every single Market no probably
not um I don't have time to go through
every single chart with you today but
you know I'm just going
through you know a nice uh a nice
grouping here's Dax okay Dax eight range
chart eight range chart I got to admit
on daxis is kind of a fast moving uh
chart
um you here you got a nice little sell
here the sell fails here's a buy you
know stops youall before it goes up know
it's sort of the same thing here here's
a nice straight down move here you know
it might have popped up stopped you out
but again you know maybe maybe not it
depends on how you're trading where your
stop placement is here's a nice one a
nice monster move down you know like I
said you know can you take this small
loss here here to catch this move you
know these are the moves that you want
to catch right you could take your small
losses you know here and here if you're
getting moves like this you know from 1
uh 12300 down to you know 285 then
you're just risking five ticks five
ticks here and then you know every once
in a while you get the um you know the
40 Point
move you know here's some nice little
trades here
here I didn't even see how it did uh you
know in then 1:00 again
1:00 honestly you know after 10: um
10:30 cash close in Europe you know you
really shouldn't be trading things like
the deck you though you do get nice
moves um I just prefer not to not to
trade it when the underline is
closed okay what else do I got here I'll
show you uh japen
um one minute chart one minute chart is
kind of fast again you on the end
sometimes you don't get a lot of
volume um you know just going back you
get some nice moves up here you know
again you know if you're trading on a
dome right you just want to know where
the next few ticks are and you know
you're getting you know some nice you
know straight up straight down straight
down straight up straight down straight
up you know here you get a nice move
here but again you know if you're
scalping for just a few ticks you know
this tool can help you you know boom
here here you nothing here
nothing
there then you're coming into you 1:00
you're not going to trade this so you'd
be a fool to take any sort of trade off
this or even here you know you need know
you got information you got something
that's going to move the market coming
out I know some people have a trading
system right around this the FED
announcement and I was like give me a
freaking Break um here this one does
again you know this doesn't work out
that doesn't work out but then boom here
you know here so you even where are we
now night session
yeah Japanese again that's a one minute
chart same settings as I'm looking at
the crude at at
Dax let me
[Music]
see what other charts we look at
here uh well you know I'll show you on
the British pound
chart can't find my my
uh other chart my bar charts I'll show
you on the footprint footprint chart
make it easier for you so you 139 you
get this nice little buy right off your
low rallies up to new highs new
highs right off this High you got a sell
came down in here you got some more buys
up to new
highs you know right on your high you
got the
sell comes off a little bit before you
rally up to uh new Highs at 1:00 though
again you know this sell is 1250 again
1:00 you got a Fed announcement you're
probably not going to want to take it
um yeah then that was it for the day but
you know it looks a little actually
looks a bit cleaner on
uh on the bar chart if I could just find
that bar
chart but anyway um
anyway I can't but um again I'll show
you a eurocurrency
chart and same thing is is similar to
the the Yen chart and you're getting
these nice little moves here again if
you're you're trading you know just for
the next few ticks if you're trading on
a dome you know any little thing that's
you going to give you some sort of edge
is going to help you I mean you know
you're talking how many ticks here not
much you know two or three ticks two or
three ticks two or three ticks but if
you're only risking two or three ticks
mean if you're in and out in and out in
and out out you know then okay you know
this this tool will help you again I'm
not going to say yeah you take this
position at at 1255 and look how you
know it worked out know you know later
when it settled down you know you're
getting a nice trade here from you know
70 uh sorry from 20 and a half 20 I what
you want to call it 22 23 all the way up
into the
60s um you I'm just curious how it
looked on the F minute chart again you
know same settings on on this euro
currency chart let me just see if I can
dig up the uh five minute chart on the
Euros euro
currency five minute chart same settings
71252 you could just see it already here
boom nice buy boom it's buy not much it
just sort of sideways on you after the
announcement okay again I'm not saying
yeah you should be taking that literally
the next bar on a five you know 105
after this F announcement again just as
I'd say you shouldn't be taking this I'd
say you shouldn't take even though it
looks nice you know I'm going to
disqualify this one this nice winner I'm
going to disqualify this loser just
because again I don't want to be taking
any position leading up to the
announcement now you know that said you
you'll make the argument well it's you
know 12:20 yeah but you know it's a f
minute chart so you're probably going to
be holding it for an hour maybe and
you're going to run into the
announcement okay I mean if you took it
yeah you would have been stopped out in
the next bar okay great but you know I
know that taking a trade on a f minute
chart you know if I want to give it you
know 10 bars to see if it's going to
work or not then you know that's 50
minutes it's close to an hour um you
know so you know even though you can
look back on this trade it's a nice
winner um I'm just call I'm not I'm not
going to take it you know five minutes
after I've been around the Market's long
enough to know you got to let the market
settle down you know 5 minutes is
probably the
minimum that you should be letting
settle
down okay
so what
else anyway that's the British pound
chart but um so anyway you know I'll end
this now it's already about 15 minutes
long this uh again you know if you're
interested in Deltas scalper go to
deltas scaler.com
and you can buy it there or you know if
you need to upgrade go to upgrade if
you're a member of the Inner Circle you
can download it from the in Circle I
fixed the link in there for you guys and
I know some people are having problems
um trying to download it it's this
stupid thing with the software for the
Inner Circle I I I got to click this
thing that says you know it's free you
that's why people were trying to
download it from the inner circle but
couldn't um because I didn't click one
little button but anyway i' I've
resolved that so um you can download it
if you're a member of the Inner Circle
you can download it for free that's why
again I don't talk much about the inter
circle but if you're a member it does uh
have its benefits you get get the
indicators for free so thanks everyone
bye-bye